It is truly stunning, but not surprising how
quickly the biggest anti cancel culture activists
have gone full council culture. They seem to have
no shame. They seem to have no even understanding
of what they are doing. And it is amazing how
quickly the biggest advocates for never regulating
business are now saying. To businesses, what
they can and should say and when they should just
shut their mouths and say nothing. Fox and Friends
has been just one data point. Fox News in general
has been just one data point of the types that
have been railing against so-called cancer
culture for months. Freedom of speech is under
attack. They want to cancel Easter. They want to
cancel prayer. They want to cancel Dr Seuss.
The people and businesses are being punished
by the left for wrong thing and wrong speech
and all of this stuff. And since the Georgia
voter suppression bill has led to various
organizations and businesses to say simply,
we'd rather not do business with Georgia, in
Georgia, we're going to go somewhere else instead.
Everybody has reversed Donald Trump released
his list of companies to counter boycott. Rand
Paul says boycott Coca-Cola. Mitch McConnell says
corporate CEOs should shut up about politics, but
keep donating to me. And now Fox News isn't even
pretending anymore. Here is a segment in which
they ran a list of companies that have criticized
the Georgia law on a crawl up the screen. And you
will notice that what they are criticizing here is
criticizing speech. Speech in which you criticize
is just talking it's speech. And they are saying
punish these businesses for criticizing, which is
another word for speaking. Check out this clip.
Let's let's look at the list. Other companies and
organizations that have criticized the Georgia
voting law. Now, we're not saying that they're
boycotting, but they're criticizing. And that's
where these things sometimes can start. I say
sometimes we can't tell the future. But from what
what you're saying, Atlanta, all of Georgia can
be hurt by these decisions. And I want to point
out who did their homework on Denver, who did
their homework on Colorado. Compare the voter
laws. I don't know, guys. I'm starting to think
that the right may not be sincere about their
supposed values of free speech and of businesses
doing what they want without punishment and being
against cancelation and being against boycotts.
It's almost like they only advocate for these
values when it's convenient and when it doesn't
conflict with whatever else they want. And then
they will quickly abandon the values when it does.
And by the way, their list is now way bigger than
any list I've ever seen on the left, which is like
it's an insignificant but also compelling little
detail. This is a list that the left can use,
though, if you want. I'm not saying do
this, but you could if you want, you could
look at that list that Fox News crawled and you
could contact those very same companies and say,
I support what you were doing in speaking out
against voter suppression. That's speech you
could use to counter their speech meant to counter
the corporate speech, which is part of the fight
against voter suppression. Consider how absurd it
is when people get boycotts going against Fox News
advertisers, Fox News hosts and right wingers
and Trump. And they say that's bad, that's cancel
culture. But then the next thing you know, Fox
News is running a crawl with a list of companies
they don't like that they want people to target.
These people are pathetic. And this is why,
you know, I don't necessarily want to open up this
can of worms right now. But some of you know that
I've done interviews before with sometimes
it's with enlightened centrists, sometimes
it's with anti-war focused. Sometimes it's just
random callers. When we open up the phone lines,
who will say, David, you're not talking
enough and being clear about your principle,
what is your principle about ABCDE? And as I've
pointed out many times, I have no issue talking
about principles. But there's two problems with
the talking only about principles. One, you end
up in a philosophical, theoretical black hole that
does very little to help you figure out real world
situations. Most real world situations aren't
resolved in any sensible way by just saying,
let me run the facts through my
principles and then I get an answer.
The hard work actually is understanding how to
balance values, principles and the facts on the
ground. That's really the work. And so I don't
find it particularly I don't find it innovative,
I don't find it productive, and I don't find it
particularly enlightened to sort of recede from
the facts of what's going on on this planet and
to just have conversations about principles and
values. I think it helps you solve very,
very little. And I've said that before.
But the more I don't know about more
important, but the more pressing reason
why just the discussions about principles in
the absence of of reality is a waste of time,
is that people will very quickly abandon their
principles anyway. The principle of free speech
and of being against business regulation.
Look at how quickly it's gone into the
trash. Trump has released a list of companies to
boycott. Fox News is running a crawl. Rand Paul
excuse me, says boycott Coca-Cola. Mitch McConnell
says corporate CEOs should shut up even though his
value is a free speech and corporations doing
whatever they want. Why engage with people
on values and principles when they only stand
behind those to the point that it is politically
convenient and when it's not, they abandon them
as well. All of these people are pathetic. They're
all bad faith actors and in some cases ignorant.
It's also it can be a combination of the two.